SEASON.
FORSBERG.
THEY GET INTO IT IN FRONT OF
THE NET.
TORONTO, PHYSICAL WITH AUSTIN
AND WATSON.
THAT'S BROKEN UP.
DEFLECTED AROUND.
AARON N
DESPITE MISSING TIME.
>> 15 MULTI POINT NAMES FOR
ALEKSANDER BARKOV
HE HAS BEEN SINCE BEING, THEY C
PART OF THEIR UNIT.
MASON MARCHMENT, A
AND ANTON FORSBERG,
ERE BY
MARCHMAN?
>> IT HAD TO BE A SEE.
TWO HIS STICK WAS TIED UP.
ALWAYS TRYING TO DO IS GET IN
POSI PLAY WAS STILL
ON.
OTTAWA
AVERAGING ONE POINT PER GAME.
>> THAT'S WHAT THE PANTHER
COACHES WANT.
THEY WANT TO SEE MORE
SAM REINHART,  BARKOV  SCOTT, A
VIRUS,  PATRIC  AAROROGET A WHI
HE'S COME UP
WE'LL START WITH A BUGGY WAY
AGAIN.
JONATHAN HUBERDEASHUFFLES IT
TOWARDS THE GOAL.
ANTON FORSBERG WAS HUGGING THAT
PATR
OTTAWAHE 20 MINUTES, THEY BE --
YOU ARE AROUND 70 IN THE GAME,
YO
COLLATION.
CARTER VERHAEGHE.
FEEDS JONATHAN HUBERDEAU , ODNE
RACKET GOES, ALEKSANDER BARKOV
, A DIFFERENT LOOK, HERE. AND W
WHISTLE.
>> THEY NEED TO GET SOME DUCT
TAPE
NOT MUCH DOING ON THIS POWER
PLAYTIME.
LET'S SEE IF HE CAN BE THE  TRU
PANTHERS FINALLY GETS ONE
ALL O
OFFENSIVE ZONETHE PANTHERS
PLAYED AS A TEAM, STUCK UP FROM
THEMSELVES.THE
BIG HITS.
BUT HE LOVES GETTING ON THE
POWER PLAY, AS